hey guys
are you redoing it hey guys it's me
like every 30 minutes
i don't do this
apparently there are still tears left to
cry but they're the good kind
[Music]
and we are living for this moment ariana
grande teaming up with drag races got
mick for one extra amusing makeup
tutorial
hi guys it is me got meg no idea what's
going on but we thought it would be fun
to just sit down
kiki together and get into rem beauty
ari could not contain her excitement
during the youtube collab which was all
for her beauty line who's the scourge
palette
baby doll i use this every day this is
my everyday one makeup talk came only
after this intro i think i should just i
want to put it on you yeah and make you
a little draggy love that hey guys
are you redoing it hey guys it's me
like every 30 minutes
hey guys it's me by the way again still
me which ari kind of struggled through
in the best way hey guys i'm sorry mo
i don't do this
i'm literally gonna cry too
i don't
oh my god i'm new here
the fun continues after that but not
before the grammy winner suggests got
mick change up his look dude i feel like
you need the pony
going we're going yep that's the makeup
artist rocking ari's signature pony do
whatever you want
whatever you want whatever feels natural
be yourself it turns out the position
singer is a huge fan of gotmick even
paying homage to him in the past by
attempting to do his signature makeup
guess who doesn't know how to do drag
makeup
[Laughter]
love you love you so much
ari wasn't too happy with it but gottmix
sent love to her in a repost writing i
live my gorge twin this is actually the
first time we've met i know but we like
that is so
crazy and don't worry got make got ari's
wing to look perfect by the end of the
tutorial we had so much fun this is the
final ariam beauty look
i love you too i'm so happy we finally
did that now while this transformation
was a total sleigh we're greedy for more
[Music]
lucky for us we know more serves are on
the way from ari because she'll soon be
sliding into glinda the good witch's
iconic fashions for the big screen
adaptation of wicked it's a very
exciting thing for us starring alongside
ari in the film cynthia arrivo who's
playing elphaba aka the future wicked
witch of the west
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the oscar winner singing a
snippet of for good on the late late
show monday night it's a song she and
ari will duet in the movie and when e.t
chatted with cynthia over the weekend
she couldn't help but gush over her
soon-to-be co-star i can tell you that
ariana is wonderful that the two of us
are starting to really like find our
feet and find our relationship and
really like enjoy one another's time and
space and conversations she's the
sweetest person and that john chu is
excited very very excited he's working
very hard that i think it's going to be
unlike anything you've ever seen i'm
sure um that i think we're going to
really enjoy the magic of it and and
we're going to try and put our own spin
on on what we know already and and show
you a story about two women that are
when i think about like the one-on-one
vocal battles
that you two can have it gives me chill
bucks i'm not even lying two of us are
definitely excited to sing together
that's definitely something that we're
both really excited about
[Music]
you